So, Valerie--
那么，瓦莱丽——
Yes.
是的。
You're a producer here on our show.
你是我们节目的制作人。
I am.
我是。
Your tone of voice betrays a lack of enthusiasm for the story you're about to tell me.
你的语调泄露了你对接下来要讲的故事缺乏热情。
Yes. I do not find this funny. I find this deeply uncomfortable.
是的。我觉得这并不好笑。我觉得这非常令人不适。
Valerie Kipnis is one of our younger and newer producers here. She's been working on the show for less than a year. And it was other staff members who urged her to come into the studio with me and tell me the story. Because they think it's funny, even if Valerie doesn't.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们这里最年轻、最新的制作人之一。她在节目组工作还不到一年。是其他同事催促她和我一起进演播室讲这个故事。因为他们觉得这很有趣，尽管瓦莱丽并不这么认为。
OK, it takes place in a subway.
好吧，故事发生在地铁上。
OK.
好的。
OK, so I get on the subway and I see this person I know on the same subway train.
好的，我上了地铁，在同一列车上看到了一个我认识的人。
Well, that's a coincidence. It doesn't happen very often.
嗯，那真是个巧合。这种情况并不常见。
No. I've never seen this person on this stop before, no. And I'm like, I should say something to this person. And I'm like thinking in my head-- I'm like, all right, I should say something. I should say something. And then he looks at me. And he makes like direct eye contact.
没错。我以前从未在这个站见过这个人。我就想，我应该跟这个人打个招呼。我在心里琢磨——我想，好吧，我应该说点什么。我应该说点什么。然后他看向了我。他和我有了直接的眼神接触。
And I'm like, right, this is my chance. I'm going to say something right now. And I open my mouth. And I'm like-- and then he starts looking at his phone. And I'm like, OK, that actually wasn't direct eye contact. That was like staring-through-you eye contact.
我就想，对，机会来了。我现在就要说点什么。我张开嘴，正要——然后他开始看手机。我就想，好吧，那其实不是直接的眼神接触。那是一种“看穿你”的眼神接触。
How far are you from him?
你离他有多远？
Six feet.
六英尺（约1.8米）。
Six feet? It's so close, right, but so far. She's by the subway doors. He's at the pole in the middle of the aisle.
六英尺？太近了，对吧，但也太远了。她站在地铁门边。他站在车厢中间的扶手杆旁。
So then, anyways, in my head, I'm like, OK, he'll probably get off on the next stop. It's not a big deal. He hasn't seen me. I'll just pretend I don't see him. But then, a few stops later, he has not gotten off. And he comes to stand right next to me, like shoulder to shoulder.
所以，不管怎样，我在心里想，好吧，他可能下一站就下车了。没关系的。他还没看到我。我就假装没看见他。但几站过后，他还没下车。他走过来站在我旁边，简直是肩并肩。
And I'm like, oh, my god. He's definitely noticed me. He's going to say something. I should say something back. And I'm looking. And he's just frantically scrolling on his phone, reading something really important, listening to something. I don't know. And I'm like, OK-- OK, I won't say anything again.
我就想，天哪。他肯定注意到我了。他要说点什么了。我也该回应点什么。我看着他，他只是在手机上疯狂滑动，读着什么很重要的东西，或者听着什么。我不知道。我就想，好吧——好吧，我还是什么都不说了。
Because you don't want to interrupt him?
因为你不想打断他？
Yeah, because I'm like, if he wanted to talk to me, he would say something.
对，因为我想，如果他想跟我说话，他会开口的。
She keeps thinking, he'll get off at any minute. After all, he went to stand by the door, right by her. But he doesn't get off, not at the next station or the next or the next. And at some point she realizes--
她一直以为他随时会下车。毕竟，他都走到车门边，站在她旁边了。但他没下车，下一站、再下一站、再下一站都没下。某一刻她意识到——
This is going to be a long ride. This isn't one or two stops. This is like a 35-minute subway ride where this person that I know very well is sitting next to me and I'm not saying anything. And our shoulders are next to one another's. And the subway is jolting. And I feel his shoulder on my shoulder. And I'm like, he's going to notice. But it's too late to say anything at this point.
这会是一段漫长的旅程。这不是一两站的事。这是一段长达35分钟的地铁行程，我非常熟悉的人坐在我旁边，而我却一言不发。我们的肩膀靠在一起。地铁在颠簸。我能感觉到他的肩膀贴着我的肩膀。我想，他一定会注意到的。但现在说什么都已经太晚了。
Wait, wait, let me just pause on that. Because now the fact that you haven't said something makes it more awkward if suddenly you go, oh, it's you.
等等，等等，让我停一下。因为现在你没打招呼这个事实，让你突然说“哦，是你啊”变得更尴尬了。
Exactly. But then it's-- in my head, I'm like, it's even more awkward if he turns to me and is like, has she been here the whole time and hasn't said anything? So in my head, I think this is a good idea. And I take out a magazine. And I flip it open as if I'm reading it. But I go like this.
正是如此。但在我脑海里，我想，如果他转过头问我：“她一直在那儿吗？怎么一声不吭？”那样会更尴尬。所以我觉得这主意不错。我拿出一本杂志。我把它翻开，假装在看。但我做了一个动作。
So you're holding the magazine up to your face?
你是把杂志举到脸前吗？
Uh-huh, so he won't see me.
嗯哼，这样他就看不见我了。
Just so it's clear what we're describing here. Valerie is holding the magazine to her face so the top of the magazine is near her hairline. So she's like a nearly blind monk trying to squint at words in a Bible, or like an extra in an old musical where-- I don't know-- Sky Masterson or Auntie Mame or whoever is going to walk into a subway car. And everybody in the car has a magazine held up to his or her face so that they can pull them down on cue and start singing. The magazine is too close to her eyes to actually read it.
为了说清楚我们描述的画面。瓦莱丽把杂志举在脸前，杂志顶部靠近发际线。她就像一个几乎失明的僧侣，试图眯着眼看圣经里的字，又或者像老音乐剧里的临时演员，不管是谁——斯凯·马斯特森还是玛姆姑妈——要走进地铁车厢。车厢里的每个人都举着杂志挡在脸前，好让他们能按预设的节奏放下杂志开始歌唱。杂志离她的眼睛太近了，根本没法读上面的字。
No normal human reads magazines in this way. And the whole time I'm thinking, he's going to notice that I didn't say anything and why didn't I-- and I keep thinking, should I have just said something? I don't know.
正常人绝不会这样看杂志。我一直在想，他会注意到我一直没说话吗？为什么我没说？我一直在想，我当时是不是应该打个招呼？我不知道。
Do you think it's possible that he's having the same experience you're having?
你觉得有没有可能他和你有着一样的经历？
Absolutely not.
绝对不可能。
Why?
为什么？
I just know it.
我就是知道。
How?
怎么知道？
Because I don't think people feel-- I don't know. I don't think people feel this way. Do people feel this way?
因为我不觉得人们会——我不知道。我不觉得人们会有这种感觉。大家真的会有这种感觉吗？
You're a person and you feel this way.
你也是人，你就有这种感觉。
But, no, I don't think he notices me. Or if he does, this makes this so much worse.
但，不，我不觉得他注意到我了。或者如果他注意到了，那只会让情况更糟。
Is this somebody who you're scared of?
你怕这个人吗？
No.
不。
It sounds like you're scared of them.
听起来你好像很怕他。
No, I'm not scared of them. But scared in a normal scared kind of way.
不，我不是怕他。只是那种普通意义上的“怕”吧。
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
Well, this guy's my boss.
嗯，这家伙是我老板。
Was it me?
是我吗？
Yes.
是的。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Yes, 100%.
是的，百分之百。
[CHUCKLING] I absolutely did not see you.
[轻笑] 我绝对没有看到你。
See? I knew it. But I was sweating underneath my winter jacket. It was one of the worst 40 minutes in my life.
你看？我就知道。但在冬装外套下，我一直在冒汗。那是我人生中最糟糕的40分钟之一。
Yeah, I didn't see you. If I had seen you, I would have said "hello."
是啊，我没看到你。如果我看到你，我肯定会打个招呼的。
But, OK, can I tell you another detail that's important?
但是，好吧，我能告诉你另一个重要的细节吗？
Yeah.
可以。
This is so weird. You weren't wearing a suit. And in my head, I had never seen you without a suit. So I thought, maybe he doesn't want to be perceived. I was just like, maybe this is Ira's private time.
这太奇怪了。你没穿西装。在我印象里，我从没见过你不穿西装的样子。所以我当时想，也许他不想被认出来。我就觉得，这可能是艾拉的私人时间。
So it was like seeing a teacher outside of the classroom when you're in elementary school? It just seemed wrong that you were seeing me there without my uniform on.
所以这就像在小学时看到老师出现在教室外一样？看到我没穿“制服”出现在那儿，让你觉得很不适应。
Yes, yes, you were wearing sneakers. I'd never seen you wear sneakers. And I was like, I can't-- I can't say anything now.
是的，是的，你穿着运动鞋。我从没见过你穿运动鞋。我当时想，我——我现在肯定不能说话了。
What was I doing?
我当时在做什么？
Frantically scrolling on your phone.
在手机上疯狂滑动。
When you say frantically scrolling through my phone, I was frantic for like a 30-minute subway ride?
当你提到我在手机上疯狂滑动时，我真的在那30分钟的地铁行程里一直很疯狂吗？
I think you were actually reading something. It was not frantic in any way. But in my head, I was like, he's frantically trying to avoid me so he's scrolling.
我觉得你其实是在看什么东西。一点都不疯狂。但在我脑海里，我想，他是在拼命试图避开我，所以才在那儿划手机。
Did you think I would get mad at you?
你觉得我会生你的气吗？
No, but I thought you'd be annoyed. You'd be like, hey, I didn't say anything for a reason, Val.
不，但我以为你会心烦。你会想，嘿，瓦尔，我没说话是有原因的。
Can I ask you a personal question?
我能问个私人问题吗？
Yeah.
可以。
Were you raised by people who didn't provide you a lot of reassurance that they liked you?
你成长过程中，抚养你的人是不是很少给你“他们很喜欢你”这种安全感？
Yeah, I'm a Soviet immigrant, duh.
是啊，我是苏联移民，废话。
It's kind of hard to get my head around it that she and I stood next to each other on a train for half an hour and our shoulders were knocking against each other and I didn't notice her and she said nothing and held a magazine to her face like a force field protecting herself and keeping us separate.
很难想象她和我竟在火车上肩并肩站了半小时，我们的肩膀撞在一起，我没发现她，而她什么也没说，还把杂志举在脸前像个保护罩，把自己保护起来，隔开了我们。
Ira, can I ask this last question?
艾拉，能问最后一个问题吗？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
Why didn't you see me?
你为什么没看到我？
Oh, I can totally tell you why I didn't see you.
噢，我完全可以告诉你我为什么没看到你。
OK.
好的。
I just really can shut out the world really, really well and just decide to focus on something. And then in a work context, it's really handy. I can write anywhere. But in personal situations, all the time-- I don't know-- I can be in the same room as somebody and be thinking about something or focused on something.
我真的能把外界彻底屏蔽掉，然后专注做某件事。在工作场合，这很有用。我可以在任何地方写作。但在私人场合，经常这样——我不知道——我可能和某人待在同一个房间里，却因为在思考或专注于某事。
I totally shut them out. They'll say something to me and I don't even hear it, which is bad. And the people in my life don't love this. And this thing on the train is an example of it.
我完全把他们隔绝了。他们会对我说些什么，我甚至都听不到，这很糟糕。我生活中的人并不喜欢这样。火车上的这件事就是一个例子。
Yeah.
是的。
确实。
It's funny. I feel the exact opposite in a bad way.
挺有意思的。我觉得正好相反，而且是往坏的方向。
You're just always aware of others around you?
你总是时刻关注着周围的人？
Hyper aware to the point where I make up things maybe or I misperceive.
过度敏感，甚至到了我可能会凭空臆想或者产生误解的地步。
Yeah. That seems hard.
嗯。那挺累人的。
Yeah.
确实。
Today on our show, we have other stories of people who are so close, but so far. Act 1 is about two people in one of the closest relationships possible. They're engaged to be married. But they have this distance between them that they cannot make sense of.
今天我们的节目里还有其他关于人们彼此靠得极近，却又极远的故事。第一幕关于一段极其亲密的关系中的两个人。他们已经订婚了。但他们之间存在着一种无法理解的距离。
Act 2, comedian Tig Notaro has a story of somebody as close as her actual bedside, and also in another way, impossibly far away. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
第二幕，喜剧演员蒂格·诺塔罗讲述了一个人，距离她近得就像在床边，但又在某种意义上遥不可及。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Love and Other Exports. How much can you trust whether somebody who you think is close to you really is close to you? Saidu Tejan-Thomas Jr. has been thinking about that question since visiting with some of his childhood friends. Saidu was born in Sierra Leone, but moved to the States when he was little. His story starts in Freetown during a recent trip home. Heads up, this story acknowledges the existence of sex.
第一幕，爱与出口。当你觉得某人离你很近时，你能在多大程度上相信他们真的与你亲近？塞杜·泰詹-托马斯一直在思考这个问题，自从他去拜访了一些童年好友之后。塞杜出生在塞拉利昂，但在很小的时候就搬到了美国。他的故事开始于最近一次回弗里敦的旅程。提示：本故事涉及性话题。
When I left Sierra Leone at eight years old, I left behind a small group of friends I did everything with. As kids, we would run around the city and play soccer at the beach. That's how we bonded. Now that we're grown when I go back, we go to the gym. It's how we pick up where we left off.
当我八岁离开塞拉利昂时，我留下了一群一起做任何事的好友。小时候，我们会在城里到处跑，在沙滩上踢足球。那就是我们建立感情的方式。现在我们长大了，我回去的时候，我们就一起去健身房。这是我们延续过去关系的方式。
[GRUNTING]
[呼哧声]
My friends have this one particular gym they like. It's called Sonics.
朋友们有一个特别喜欢的健身房。叫Sonics。
1, 2, 3, and 4, 5, more, 6, more, 7.
1、2、3、4，再做5个，再做6个，7。
Sonics sits at the end of a dirt road in Freetown, a small space in a quaint green and yellow building. It has no air conditioning and relentless heat. So the guys are usually drenched in sweat like oiled-up extras in '90s R&B videos. I come here almost every time I'm in Salone.
Sonics位于弗里敦一条土路的尽头，是一栋古雅的绿黄色小房子里的一小块空间。这里没有空调，酷热难耐。所以男人们通常汗流浃背，就像90年代R&B音乐录影带里涂了油的临时演员。我几乎每次回塞拉利昂都会来这儿。
But then the last time we went, I discovered that for many of the guys here, all their crunches and squats had a much deeper purpose than looking good. The gym, my friends told me, possesses a special luck for young Sierra Leonean men who want to move to America or Europe.
但上次我们去的时候，我发现对于这里的许多人来说，他们所有的仰卧起坐和深蹲，其目的远不止是为了好看。我的朋友告诉我，这家健身房对于想要移民到美国或欧洲的塞拉利昂年轻男性来说，拥有一种特殊的运气。
They believe that if you use the weights here to sculpt your body, make it beautiful enough, you will find a wife overseas, and that Sonics has a track record to prove it. A member named Savage told me about how foolproof this method has been for previous members. He's speaking in Krio. I'll paraphrase after.
他们相信，如果你利用这里的器械雕塑身材，练得足够漂亮，你就能在海外找到妻子，而Sonics有成功案例为证。一位成员名叫萨维奇，他告诉我这个方法对以往的成员来说是多么万无一失。他用克里奥语说，稍后我会转述。
We not ever get a situation where we get member, we meet with JC, then they normally come up together.
（克里奥语内容）
We've never had a Sonics member who dates someone visiting from overseas who doesn't end up marrying them.
我们从来没有出现过那种会员，只要和海外回来的人约会，最后没有结成婚的。
They may come up and then travel.
她们可能回来，然后就一起出国了。
So you have a high success rate?
所以你们的成功率很高？
Oh, yes. Oh, yes. We have barrage of them, barrage of them.
噢，是的。噢，是的。我们有大批这样的人，大批。
Another member of Sonics, this guy with perfectly sculpted arms called Sultan, jumped in to name their legends, the guys they've heard found wives overseas, success stories that get passed around at the gym.
Sonics的另一位成员，那个手臂肌肉练得非常完美、叫苏丹的人，插话列举了他们的传奇人物，那些他们听说在海外找到妻子的伙计们，这些在健身房里广为流传的成功故事。
Balance... Salam... Brasiliki...
巴兰斯……萨拉姆……巴西利奇……
There was a driver who chauffeured a Black American woman around Freetown while she was visiting, always making sure to look presentable doing it. He made a good impression. They got married. And he just went to America a few months ago.
有个司机，他在一位美国黑人女性来弗里敦旅游时负责开车，工作时总是表现得彬彬有礼。他留下了很好的印象。他们结婚了。几个月前他刚去了美国。
Scientis... Alpha...
赛恩蒂斯……阿尔法……
There was the handsome photographer who got a random phone call from a Sierra Leonean woman living in London. It was a wrong number but he charmed his way into a conversation, sent her some photos of his biceps, and they got married last year. He's now living with her in London.
有个帅气的摄影师，接到了一个住在伦敦的塞拉利昂女人的随机电话。是个拨错的号码，但他凭魅力开启了对话，给她发了几张二头肌照片，去年他们结婚了。他现在和她在伦敦生活。
Next sets, next sets. Next, come on.
下一组，下一组。下一位，快点。
I respected the hustle. But their plans somehow didn't sit right with me. The idea of guys I grew up with, men in my country using their bodies to get overseas, it made me uncomfortable. But then I sat down with a few of the guys and we started to talk. And I realized beneath the surface, beyond all the muscles, confidence, and bravado, all of these men were carrying around a broken heart, which brings me to the guy I wanted to talk to the most, my friend Mark.
我尊重这种拼劲。但他们的计划在某种程度上让我感到不安。我从小一起长大的朋友，我国家的人，利用自己的身体去海外，这让我感到不舒服。但后来我和其中几个人坐下来聊了聊。我意识到，在表面之下，在那所有的肌肉、自信和虚张声势背后，这些男人都带着一颗破碎的心。这让我想到了我最想交谈的一个人，我的朋友马克。
MC Mark, Mario Mark, Mario Mark.
MC马克，马里奥·马克，马里奥·马克。
(SINGING) How do I breathe? How do I breathe?
（唱歌）我该如何呼吸？我该如何呼吸？
Mark and I grew up in the same neighborhood. But we didn't really get to know each other until we were grown. He's a good-looking guy who's easy to talk to. Not the greatest singer, but we were hanging out one day and he decided to sing me his favorite love song.
马克和我在同一个社区长大。但直到我们成年，才真正熟络起来。他长得很帅，很好说话。歌唱得不是最好，但有一天我们在闲逛，他决定唱他最喜欢的爱情歌给我听。
(SINGING) --feels so different being here. I was so used to being next to you. Life for me is not the same. There is no one to talk to.
（唱歌）……这里的一切感觉如此不同。我习惯了你在身边。我的生活已不再一样。无人可诉说。
Mario's "How Do I Breathe," one of my favorite songs, is a song about a guy trying to piece together his emotional life after losing the woman he loves. It's basically Mark's story. It's why he's the one of my friends who believes most fervently that finding love overseas is the way to go. The girl he's singing about is someone he grew up with. Mark says she was the smartest kid in their fifth grade class. But she was always approachable. And he liked that. He liked that they could joke together.
马里奥的《我该如何呼吸》，我最喜欢的歌之一，讲述了一个男人在失去挚爱后试图拼凑起自己情感生活的故事。这基本上就是马克的经历。这就是为什么他是朋友中最坚信“在海外寻找爱情”就是出路的那一个。他歌里唱的那个女孩是他从小一起长大的。马克说她是五年级班上最聪明的孩子。但她总是很平易近人。他喜欢那一点。他喜欢他们能在一起开玩笑。
After lessons, they would go to the beach and talk for hours, getting to know each other. He says she was the first person who taught him how to love. Like this one day, he walked home from prayers and as soon as he opened the door, he saw her standing there with all his best friends from school, his family, everyone, singing.
放学后，他们会去海滩聊上几个小时，互相了解。他说她是第一个教他如何去爱的人。就像有一天，他从祈祷回来，一开门，就看到她站在那儿，和他学校所有的好朋友、家人，所有人在一起唱歌。
Happy birthday to you. Really surprised me. Come, you hug me. It's like, ah! Really, really happy-- I really, really-- I was just-- I just start crying.
祝你生日快乐。真的给了我惊喜。过来，你拥抱我。就像，啊！真的，真的很高兴——我真的，真的——我只是——我只是开始哭。
She'd planned this elaborate surprise party for his 14th birthday, complete with all his favorite food and all the people he loved. And on top of all that, she gave him a kiss.
她为他14岁生日策划了这个精心设计的惊喜派对，准备了他最喜欢的食物和他爱的人。最重要的是，她给了他一个吻。
Was it on your cheek or your mouth or your lips?
是脸颊上，还是嘴上，或者嘴唇上？
On my lips, in front of everybody-- so in front of my mom, in front of [KRIO], in front of me grandpa, me granny.
在嘴唇上，当着所有人的面——当着我妈妈的面，当着……的面，当着爷爷奶奶的面。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The kiss was so special to me, than all the kiss that anyone would ever kiss me.
那个吻对我来说，比任何人的吻都要特别。
So that was the most special kiss that you've ever had? That was like the best-- that's the best kiss you've ever had?
所以那是你经历过最特别的吻？那是你经历过最好的吻？
The best ever.
最好的，绝对是。
Neither of them came from money, far from it. But Mark was growing up with a single parent. When his mother couldn't afford to care for him, he lived with his grandpa.
他们两人家境都不好，远非如此。但马克是单亲家庭长大的。当妈妈负担不起照顾他的费用时，他寄住在爷爷家。
But then his grandpa died. Then his mother died. And Mark became an orphan. He says his relationship with this woman was one of the few things in his life that felt stable. With her, he could dream. He could escape into one of their long talks about how sweet their lives would be in the future.
但后来爷爷去世了。接着妈妈也去世了，马克成了孤儿。他说他与这个女孩的关系是他生活中为数不多感到稳定的事物之一。和她在一起，他可以做梦。他可以逃避到他们漫长的谈话中，谈论未来他们的生活会多么甜蜜。
I reached out to her to get her side of this, but she didn't want to be involved with my story and she wouldn't confirm anything Mark said. The way Mark tells it though, they had decided-- she would work in the energy industry. He would become a lawyer.
我试着联络她想听听她的版本，但她不想参与我的故事，也不愿意证实马克说的任何事。但按马克的说法，他们已经决定了——她会在能源行业工作。他会成为一名律师。
They wanted three to four kids, a house in Salone. Maybe they'd travel sometimes. I love the way he describes the love he had for her.
他们想要三四个孩子，在塞拉利昂有个家。也许偶尔去旅行。我喜欢他描述他对她那种爱的方式。
So real to me, no...
对我来说如此真实，不……
She was so real to me.
她对我来说太真实了。
If I get or not get, e nor wan know how i dae or how i look lek, na love e bin get for me.
无论我有没有钱，她不在乎我怎么过怎么看，这就是她对我的爱。
She didn't care if I had money or didn't have money. She didn't care how I looked. It's love she had for me.
她不在乎我有没有钱。她不在乎我长得怎样。这是她对我的爱。
True love from the bottom of her heart.
来自她内心深处的真爱。
And you thought to yourself, this is going to be my wife.
当时你心想，这就是我要娶的妻子。
Yeah, she's going to be my wife in the future since then.
是的，从那时候起，我就认定她会是我未来的妻子。
After they graduated high school, she got a scholarship to attend university abroad. Mark says she tried to put in a good word for him to get the same scholarship, but it didn't work out. Still, he encouraged her to go. And for three years, they continued their relationship via WhatsApp and Facebook. She told him she was one of the top students in her class.
高中毕业后，她获得了去国外留学的奖学金。马克说她曾为他美言，希望能拿到同样的奖学金，但没成功。不过，他还是鼓励她去。那三年，他们通过WhatsApp和Facebook继续保持着恋爱关系。她告诉他她是班上顶尖的学生。
Back home, Mark was struggling. He had no money, no parents, no connections in a country with no reliable jobs for young people. His dreams of becoming a lawyer were fading. But word of his girlfriend's success was starting to get around the wider Sierra Leonean community. Guys were sliding into her DMs on socials. And whenever that happened, she would tell Mark and then block them immediately, until someone new approached her.
在国内，马克在挣扎。他没钱，没父母，在这个缺乏稳定就业机会的国家没有任何人脉。他成为律师的梦想正在破灭。但关于他女朋友成就的消息开始在更广泛的塞拉利昂社区传开。男人们在社交网络上不断发私信骚扰她。每当发生这种情况，她会告诉马克，然后立即拉黑他们，直到有新人再次接近。
One time when I was sitting down, she told me that I have this guy.
有一次我坐着的时候，她告诉我，我这儿有个男的。
The guy was a Sierra Leonean doctor. He had seen one picture of Mark's girlfriend and decided that she would be his wife. Mark says she tried to ignore him, but the man contacted her family and formally asked for her hand. She told Mark they were pressuring her to accept, telling her that a marriage with this man could not only change her future, but her entire family's too.
那是个塞拉利昂医生。他看了马克女朋友的一张照片，就决定要娶她。马克说她试图无视他，但那个人联络了她的家人，正式提亲。她告诉马克，家人们在向她施压，说嫁给这个男人不仅能改变她的未来，也能改变她全家的未来。
He watched as the nine years of their relationship unraveled over a short series of tearful WhatsApp calls. Nothing Mark could say, nothing he could do, nothing he could offer her or her family was enough to convince them to choose him over a doctor. A few months later, he says she received the ring via DHL and was married to this stranger.
他眼睁睁看着九年的感情在几次充满泪水的WhatsApp通话中分崩离析。无论马克说什么，无论他做什么，无论他能为她或她的家人提供什么，都不足以让他们选择他而不是那个医生。几个月后，他说她收到了通过DHL寄来的戒指，嫁给了一个陌生人。
A doctor who don't know where you are from, who doesn't know [SUCKS TEETH]. After all the plans, after all the promises, disappointment.
一个不知道你来自哪里、不知道……的医生。在所有的计划之后，在所有的承诺之后，只有失望。
Love became disappointment?
爱变成了失望？
Yes, it changes everything because she met somebody, a doctor. The moment will hurt me the most in my life.
是的，因为她遇到了别人，一个医生。这是我一生中最痛苦的时刻。
The visionary feminist writer bell hooks says love is made up of seven parts. Wherever someone is practicing care, affection, recognition, respect, commitment, trust, and open, honest communication, there is love, even in an economically poor environment like Salone. But talking to Mark, I found myself thinking more about what love needs to survive, what conditions can make the act of loving easier or more difficult to sustain. Mark felt like he couldn't compete because of money. And he was right. Not everyone has equal access to love.
远见卓识的女性主义作家贝尔·胡克斯说过，爱由七个部分组成。无论何处，只要有人在实践关怀、爱慕、认同、尊重、承诺、信任以及坦诚的沟通，爱就在那里，即使是在像塞拉利昂这样贫穷的环境中也是如此。但和马克聊天时，我发现自己更多地在思考爱需要什么才能生存，什么样的条件能让去爱的行为变得更容易或更难维持。马克觉得因为没钱，他没法竞争。他是对的。并非所有人都能平等地获得爱。
I feel like crying. But it's shameful to cry before you. [LAUGHTER]
我感觉想哭。但在你面前哭很丢人。[笑声]
You feel like crying, but you're ashamed to cry in front of me? You should cry!
你想哭，但不好意思在我面前哭？你应该哭！
I miss those moments with her.
我怀念和她在一起的那些时光。
In the years since I left Salone, I had fantasies about the lives of people back home. Our country had been ravaged by years of war that left a lot of heartache, suffering, and poverty in its wake. But I believe that through all of that, people had each other, that they had this unbreakable bond that was vital to our survival. But Mark was telling me that was wrong.
自从离开塞拉利昂后，我就对国内人们的生活有过幻想。我们的国家饱受战争摧残，留下了很多心碎、苦难和贫困。但我相信，通过这一切，人们还有彼此，他们拥有某种对我们生存至关重要的、牢不可破的纽带。但马克却告诉我那是错的。
I don't think-- love is not here. If it is, it's at 10% or 5%.
我不认为……爱不在这个地方。如果有，也只有5%或10%。
If it is, only 10% or 5% have true love. It wasn't just Mark. Almost every guy I talked to in Freetown told me the same thing. It felt like there was this lovelessness among the men in Salone. Every time I raised a question-- and I talked to around 18 or 19 people-- they'd launch into their own stories of heartbreak.
如果真的有，只有5%或10%的人拥有真爱。不只是马克。我在弗里敦聊到的几乎每个人都告诉了我同样的事情。这感觉像是塞拉利昂的男人之间有一种“爱的缺失”。每当我提出这个问题——我聊了大约18或19个人——他们就会展开各自的心碎故事。
I heard it from the taxi drivers, coconut salesmen, hotel bellhops, random guys on the street-- women too. The guys at Sonics gym said they'd all gone through it and independently landed on the same math. I asked them what percent of people without money in Salone find true love.
我从出租车司机、卖椰子的小贩、酒店行李员、街上的随机路人那里都听到了——女人也一样。Sonics健身房的伙计们说他们都经历过，并且不约而同地得出了相同的结论。我问他们，在塞拉利昂，没钱的人里有多少比例的人能找到真爱。
What's the percent of true love without money in Salone?
在塞拉利昂，没钱获得真爱的比例是多少？
It's 5%. 5%.
是5%。5%。
5%
5%。
5%.
5%
5%。
I say, yeah, sure.
我说，啊，好吧。
When I ask my friends in America the same question about finding love without money, they say 60% to 80%.
当我问美国的那些朋友同样关于“没钱是否能找到真爱”的问题时，他们说是60%到80%。
If love was like everything else these guys couldn't afford in Salone, if it really was a luxury, it made sense to me that they thought the best course of action was to look for it abroad.
如果爱也像这些家伙在塞拉利昂买不起的一切一样，如果它真的是一种奢侈品，那么他们认为最好的出路就是去海外寻找，这对我来说就讲得通了。
It was a way to solve two problems at once. They could move to a country where poverty was less rampant and true love was more accessible. But I wondered about it. Where would it lead them? For Mark, it led him to the place most of us turn to for finding love these days, the internet.
这是一种能同时解决两个问题的方法。他们可以搬到一个贫困程度较低、真爱更容易获得的地方。但我很怀疑。这会把他们引向何方？对马克来说，这把他引向了我们现在大多数人寻找爱情的地方——互联网。
Let me see the first message you sent this person. This one is really long.
让我看看你发给这个人的第一条消息。这一条真的很长。
Really long.
真的长。
Mark got on Facebook. And he started sliding into as many DMs as possible. He didn't care about age or race or religion, just anyone who was over 18 and overseas who might be interested in a relationship.
马克上了Facebook。他开始尽可能多地给陌生人发私信。他不关心年龄、种族或宗教，只要是18岁以上、在海外且可能对一段关系感兴趣的人就行。
OK, so just tell me what you're saying in these messages. Just read them.
好吧，那就告诉我你在这些消息里说了什么。读出来就行。
Hello, Patricia-- Patricia, lover, how are you doing, dear? And she said "OK." I said, "OK, dear, it's good to hear." Then I said, "I am Mark. Nice meeting you, dear." Then she replied, "Same here."
你好，帕特里夏——帕特里夏，亲爱的，你好吗？她说“还行”。我说，“好的，亲爱的，很高兴听到这个。”然后我说，“我是马克。很高兴认识你，亲爱的。”然后她回复，“我也是。”
So you're writing a lot. You're writing a lot. [LAUGHTER] You're writing a lot. She's only responding with like one word, two word answers.
所以你写了很多。你写了很多。[笑声] 你写了很多。她只用了一两个词来回应你。
Yeah.
是的。
In his search for a new relationship, Mark messaged over 150 random people on Facebook.
在寻找新恋情的过程中，马克给Facebook上超过150个随机对象发了消息。
I said to her, Wilson, she's in America. Salma Amed America.
我对她说，威尔逊，她在美利坚。萨尔玛·阿梅德，美利坚。
Some messaged back.
有些人回复了。
[KRIO] America, coming to country, Brazil.
（克里奥语）美利坚，回国，巴西。
There was a single mom in Brazil who liked his muscles, the Sierra Leonean student in Sydney who talked to him because he reminded her of home, the nurse in London who thought he was good banter. Whenever he came across married women, he would keep it pushing. But he was hoping to connect with almost anyone overseas.
有一个在巴西的单亲妈妈喜欢他的肌肉，一个在悉尼留学的塞拉利昂学生和他聊天是因为他让她想起了家，一个伦敦的护士觉得他很风趣。每当他遇到已婚女性，他就会继续前进。但他希望联络上海外的几乎任何人。
It makes me feel good, like, talking to someone that is far away from me, like someone that is in America, you-- it would make me feel like-- I would just close my eyes. I feel like I'm in America.
这让我感觉很好，就像，和远方的人聊天，像是在美国的人……这会让我感觉——我会闭上眼睛。我觉得我就在美国。
Listening to Mark, it was like I was watching an episode of 90 Day Fiancé, but seeing the side of the story I'd always wanted to see, the version where the hopes and dreams of the foreign spouse were finally center stage. My friend Mark was eagerly searching for a love that could transform his life. He made a few connections, but most women weren't interested in a long distance relationship with a guy all the way in West Africa. So Mark struck out again and again.
听马克说话，就像在看一集《90天未婚夫》，但看到的是我一直想看到的那一面的故事——外国配偶的希望和梦想终于成为主角的版本。我的朋友马克急切地寻找着能改变他人生的爱。他确实建立了一些联系，但大多数女性对和一个远在西非的男人异地恋并不感兴趣。所以马克一次又一次地被拒。
But one significant day I found Lottie.
但在一个重要的日子，我找到了洛蒂。
He found Lottie.
他找到了洛蒂。
Lottie Rebecca Beasely.
洛蒂·丽贝卡·比斯利。
Lottie Rebecca Beasley.
She's my fiance-- she's my girlfriend. Because we don't get married to each other yet because of the distance. She's in America. I'm in Africa.
她是我的未婚妻——她是我的女朋友。因为距离的原因，我们还没结婚。她在美利坚。我在非洲。
Lottie Rebecca Beasley was a Black woman Mark met through Facebook. And he just loved how regal her name sounded, Lottie Rebecca Beasley. You've got to say all three. She had kind eyes, a warm smile, and she lived in this state that Mark had never heard of.
洛蒂·丽贝卡·比斯利是马克通过Facebook认识的一位黑人女性。他就是喜欢她名字听起来的那种高贵感，洛蒂·丽贝卡·比斯利。一定要把三个名字都念出来。她有仁慈的双眼，温暖的微笑，住在一个马克从未听说过的州。
Fairbanks, Alaska, in the morning there, here it's midnight. 1:00, 2:00, 3:00 AM in the morning, I usually wake up just to talk to Lottie until 5:00 or 6:00 AM. It's all in the morning hours.
费尔班克斯，阿拉斯加，那里是早上，这里是午夜。凌晨1点、2点、3点，我通常醒来只是为了和洛蒂说话，直到凌晨5点或6点。全都是早晨的时间。
But the nine hour time difference wasn't the only obstacle. There was another distance too.
但九个小时的时差并不是唯一的障碍。还有另一个距离。
She was born on 1949. She just turned 73 years of age this past September.
她出生于1949年。去年九月她刚满73岁。
And did you know that before you clicked on her profile?
在你点开她的资料之前知道吗？
No.
不知道。
A 70-year-old woman wasn't what Mark expected. Most of the guys at the gym who had been successful had ended up with wives closer to their own age. But while Mark had been casting a wide net in search of a relationship that could change his life, he was also open to meeting a new friend. So he didn't overthink the age thing with Lottie. And she was calm about it too. In her very first message, she roasted him about how young he was.
一个70多岁的女人并不是马克预期的。健身房里大多数成功的家伙最终找到的妻子年龄都更接近他们自己。但马克在撒网寻找能改变人生的恋情时，也愿意交新朋友。所以他没有在洛蒂的年龄问题上多想。她也很从容。在她的第一条消息里，她还嘲笑他还是个小屁孩。
They jusy say hey, who are you, little boy? Who are you, little boy? What do you want? I said, I'm not a little boy. I'm a man.
他们只是说，嘿，你是谁，小屁孩？你是谁，小屁孩？你想要什么？我说，我不是小屁孩。我是个男人。
How old were you when you met her?
你认识她的时候多大？
21 or, 22, yeah, 21 or 22.
21或22岁，是的，21或22岁。
Mark was young, but he's a good listener. Before long, Lottie was telling him all about her life. She'd gone through a lot of heartbreak too. She'd been married three times, had five children. And after one of her husbands had become abusive, she needed to get away. That's how she ended up in Alaska. She made the best of it, started her own business caring for the elderly, and was moving on with her life. She wanted to know about Mark too.
马克年轻，但他是个很好的倾听者。没过多久，洛蒂就开始告诉他关于她生活的一切。她也经历了很多心碎。她结过三次婚，有五个孩子。在其中一个丈夫变得暴力后，她不得不离开。那就是她最终来到阿拉斯加的原因。她在那儿尽力生活，开了自己的店，照顾老人，并继续前行。她也想了解马克。
What about my life? How I lost my father, I lost my mother. She said, oh, you're an orphan? I said, yes. She was having this sympathy for me. She was feeling sorry for me.
关于我的生活？我怎么失去了父亲，失去了母亲。她说，噢，你是孤儿？我说，是的。她对我产生了共鸣。她很同情我。
For Mark, this thing that began as a friendship was starting to grow. He saw a potential for a romantic relationship. But Lottie struggled to see it, even though he felt like she wanted to. The age difference was too much. Mark says most people feel that way.
对于马克，这段始于友谊的感情开始升温。他看到了恋爱关系的潜能。但洛蒂很难看到，尽管他觉得她也想要。年龄差距太大了。马克说大多数人都有这种感觉。
So when you tell-- whenever you tell people about Lottie, about your relationship with this--
所以当你说——当你告诉人们关于洛蒂，关于你和这个——
Don't believe. Don't believe. They all say, this is scam, this is scam. It's normal, though. People get their own thoughts and get their own thinking. And life, people must talk anything you do in this life. So if you live, if you stop by to listen to everyone, every word they say towards you, trust me, you won't even achieve your goal. Sometimes I'll give them deaf ears.
不相信。不相信。他们都说，这是骗局，这是骗局。不过这很正常。人们有自己的想法和思考方式。生活里，无论你做什么，人们总要说三道四。所以如果你活着，如果你停下来听每个人的话，听他们对你说的每一个字，相信我，你连目标都实现不了。有时候我会充耳不闻。
I got to say, when Mark first told me about Lottie, I had questions too. Like I wondered, was my friend now a bona fide romance scammer or something? Because it is true that the way that he was looking for love gave him the silhouette of a romance scammer.
我得说，马克第一次告诉我洛蒂的事时，我也心存疑问。比如我好奇，我的朋友现在是不是一个名副其实的婚恋骗子什么的？因为他寻找爱情的方式确实带有婚恋骗子的影子。
Scammers ask people questions about their personal life, send sweet messages. They try to earn trust before stealing your money and disappearing. But what Mark was telling me about his relationship made me believe that this wasn't that. Mark never asked for money. And he was putting in a lot of time with Lottie.
骗子会问别人的私生活问题，发送甜言蜜语。他们试图在骗钱并消失前赢得信任。但马克告诉我的关于他感情的事让我相信这不是那样。马克从没要过钱。而且他在洛蒂身上投入了大量时间。
When she was in the hospital, day and night, I check on her. I said, I'm here. We're far in distance, but you are close to my heart. I said, I'm here praying for you day and night.
她在医院的时候，没日没夜，我去看望她。我说，我在这儿。我们的距离虽然远，但你离我的心很近。我说，我在这里没日没夜地为你祈祷。
She had to accept me. Because of the way I talk to her, the way I care about her, do I call her when I woke up-- I wake up from sleep. I check on her. How are you doing? How's your health now?
她必须接受我。因为我和她交谈的方式，我关心她的方式，我醒来后会打给她——我睡醒了。我去看望她。你感觉怎么样？你的健康状况好点了吗？
Months passed and Mark and Lottie kept talking, developing a love ethic where they both showed up for each other.
几个月过去了，马克和洛蒂一直保持联络，发展出一种双方都为对方付出的爱的伦理。
At one point, she actually said, did you eat breakfast this morning?
有一次，她真的说，你今天早晨吃早餐了吗？
Did you breakfast this morning?
你今天早晨吃早餐了吗？
I said, what is breakfast. [LAUGHTER]
我说，早餐是什么。[笑声]
And I said, what is breakfast?
我说，早餐是什么？
I said, OK. I said, no. I said, no. I said, please. I said, just understand. Here in Africa, our breakfast is for the politicians-- for the presidents, politicians, first lady. I said, sometimes when I wake up in the morning, I don't even taste food 'til 12:00 PM or 3 o'clock, sometimes even in the evening hours.
我说，好的。我说，没吃。我说，不。我说，请。我说，你就理解一下吧。在非洲这里，我们的早餐是属于政客的——属于总统、政客、第一夫人。我说，有时候我早上醒来，直到中午12点或3点都尝不到食物，有时候甚至要到晚上。
Lottie asked about where Mark stayed. And he told her he shared one room with three other people. And most nights, he would have to stand outside the house to talk to her so he wouldn't disturb his roommates. This is common. Most people in Salone live on roughly $2 a day. Mark had been making a little money playing soccer in some local leagues, but it wasn't enough to get by.
洛蒂问马克住在哪里。他告诉她他和一个房间里住着三个人。大多数晚上，他都得站在屋外和她说话，以免打扰室友。这很普遍。塞拉利昂大多数人每天生活费大约2美元。马克靠在当地联赛踢球赚点钱，但不足以维持生计。
Hearing about how Mark was struggling made Lottie upset. So she decided to start sending him money. $200 covered rent for the entire year at a place all his own. She also paid for his grandma's funeral. It wasn't a huge amount, just what she could spare here and there, but it made her feel happy to help him.
听到马克的挣扎让洛蒂很难过。所以她决定开始给他寄钱。200美元就能支付他独居地方一整年的房租。她还资助了他奶奶的葬礼。数额不大，只是她偶尔能省下来的钱，但能帮到他让她感到快乐。
So when she used to call me, Mark. I said, yeah, Lottie, yes, sweetheart. She said, did you eat breakfast? Yeah. Now is the time to have breakfast. Just laughing, ah, Lottie. When I close my eyes. I just think like she's in front of me.
所以当她过去打给我，马克。我说，在呢，洛蒂，是的，亲爱的。她说，你吃早餐了吗？对。现在是吃早餐的时候了。只是笑，啊，洛蒂。当我闭上眼睛。我就觉得她就在我面前。
What do you think you were providing her? What do you think you were giving her? How were you contributing to the relationship?
你觉得你在提供给她什么？你觉得你在给予她什么？你对这段关系有什么贡献？
Because she's contributing money. And she's contributing like financially. So what do you think you were contributing to the relationship?
因为她在贡献钱。而且她在经济上做贡献。那你觉得你对这段关系有什么贡献？
Love, love and caring for her.
爱，爱，以及对她的关怀。
I can see that. A lot of relationships involve some kind of transaction. Each person brings what they can offer to the mix. With Lottie, it's money, at least partly. And with Mark, it's his time and care. When I think about the contours of their relationship, the fact that they've never met in person and live thousands of miles apart, not to mention the difference in age and experience, it makes me a little uneasy.
我能看出来。很多关系都涉及某种交易。每个人都贡献自己能提供的部分。对洛蒂而言，至少部分是钱。对马克而言，是时间和关怀。想到他们关系的轮廓，他们从未亲自见面，相隔数千英里，更不用说年龄和阅历的差距，这让我有点不安。
So did you guys talk about sex? Do you talk about sex ever?
那你们聊过性吗？你们聊过性吗？
Everything, we talk about sex, talk about everything.
所有话题，我们聊性，聊所有话题。
So how did that-- how does that-- if you don't mind me asking, so how do you--
那你们怎么——如果你不介意问的话，你们怎么——
We make sex on the phone.
我们在电话里做爱。
You guys had phone sex?
你们做过电话性爱？
Phone sex. Like we will talk when lying down. Climb onto my chest. OK. Are you there? Can I put something there? OK.
电话性爱。就像我们躺着的时候聊天。爬上我的胸口。好了。你在那儿吗？我可以放点什么在那儿吗？好的。
Let me ask you this question, actually. Are you attracted to her?
问你个问题吧，说真的。你被她吸引吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah?
真的？
Sure.
当然。
What about her are you attracted to? What turns you on about her?
你被她什么吸引？什么让你觉得兴奋？
Even she's 73 years old, she still love back. Her back is set just like Nicki Minaj. OK, Nicki Minaj is-- [LAUGHTER]
即使她73岁了，她的背影依然充满魅力。她的背影就像妮琪·米娜。好的，妮琪·米娜是——[笑声]
OK, so you think when you and her meet in person, you'll have no issue having sex with her?
所以你认为当你和她亲自见面时，和她发生性关系不会有任何问题？
I have no issue. What?
我没问题。什么？
If I'm being real, my worry for Mark isn't just about whether or not he's attracted to Lottie. There's a darker place my mind wanders off to. It's hard not to see their relationship in the context of the exploitation that's happening in West Africa right now. Sexual tourism has been a growing problem in the Gambia, for example.
说实话，我为马克担心的不只是他是否被洛蒂吸引。我的思绪飘向了一个更阴暗的地方。很难不从西非目前正在发生的剥削背景来看待他们的关系。例如，在冈比亚，性旅游就是一个日益严重的问题。
Older women have been descending on the country and spending their money on sex with young African men. The phenomenon is so rampant that the Gambian government stepped in, demanding foreign visitors stop this practice. But it still continues.
年长的女性来到这个国家，把钱花在与当地年轻男性发生性关系上。这一现象非常猖獗，以至于冈比亚政府不得不介入，要求外国游客停止这种行为。但这仍在继续。
I don't think that's what's happening with Mark and Lottie. But there are enough similarities here to make me question. And if half of me worried that my friend was being taken advantage of, the other half worried for Lottie. Because Mark talked so openly about what he hopes to get out of their relationship.
我不认为马克和洛蒂之间发生的是这种情况。但这里确实有足够的相似之处让我产生质疑。如果说我有一半担心我的朋友被利用了，另一半则在为洛蒂担忧。因为马克如此坦率地谈论他希望从这段关系中得到什么。
What did you like about her? What did you feel?
你喜欢她什么？你感觉到了什么？
You remember I told you earlier that I want to accomplish my dream. I want to go to the United States or Europe.
记得我刚才告诉过你，我想实现我的梦想。我想去美国或欧洲。
That's not feelings you have for her. That's feelings you have for your dream. Those are two different things.
那不是你对她的感觉。那是你对你梦想的感觉。那是两码事。
Yeah, if she's going-- if she's the one who's going to take me from here, then.
是的，如果她是——如果她是那个能带我离开这里的人，那么。
Then the feelings for your dreams become your feelings for her?
那么你对梦想的感觉就变成了你对她的感觉？
I've already said, Lottie, if you take me out of here, trust me, no matter the age difference, I swear to my life, we'll be together 'til God sends one home.
我已经说过了，洛蒂，如果你带我离开这里，相信我，不管年龄差距有多大，我以我的生命发誓，我们会在一起，直到上帝送走其中一个。
So you told her, you told her, if you take me out of here, I will love you forever, basically. So she knows that you, there's something that you want. She knows that there's something that you want beyond her.
所以你告诉她，你告诉她，如果你带我离开这里，我基本上会永远爱你。所以她知道你，你想要某些东西。她知道你想要的东西超越了她本身。
Yes, sure.
是的，当然。
I'd been reaching out to Lottie for weeks with no luck to get her side of all of this. Then finally, early one morning, around 3:00 AM.
我几周来一直试着联系洛蒂，但没能得到她对这一切的回应。终于，在一个清晨，大约凌晨3点。
Hello?
喂？
Hello.
喂。
She called me back. And we talked for a while. I didn't know what to expect. But Lottie was very open about her life. She told me more about her work caring for the elderly, the grandson who put her up in her own apartment when she got older, and then, of course, we talked about her feelings for Mark.
她回电了。我们聊了一会儿。我不知道会发生什么。但洛蒂对她的生活非常坦诚。她告诉了我更多关于她照顾老人的工作，她年纪大了以后收留她的孙子，当然，我们谈到了她对马克的感情。
I love Mark. I can't even understand how I fell in love with Mark. Because I ain't never dealt with no young man. I was just talking to him as a friend.
我爱马克。我甚至无法理解我是怎么爱上马克的。因为我从来没和年轻人打过交道。我只是把他当作朋友聊天。
Lottie can be a little hard to understand sometimes. It's because of a botched intubation she went through years ago. But I have to say, despite that, she doesn't come off as the kind of person who doesn't have agency over her life. At 73, she can clearly hold her own.
洛蒂的话有时候有点难懂。那是因为她几年前经历过一次失败的插管手术。但我必须说，尽管如此，她给人的感觉并不是那种无法掌控自己生活的人。73岁时，她显然能独当一面。
And I don't let nothing stop me. Do you see my picture on Facebook?
我从不让任何事阻止我。你看到我Facebook上的照片了吗？
Yeah, yeah, I've seen it.
看到了，看到了，我看到了。
Do I look like I'm 73 years old?
我看起来像73岁吗？
My mother definitely taught me better than to comment on a woman's age. But I will say, in Lottie's profile picture, she has a very youthful energy about her. In our conversation, she confirmed all of what Mark said about their relationship and how intense their connection was from the start.
我母亲确实教过我，评价女人的年龄是不礼貌的。但我会说，在洛蒂的个人头像里，她有一种非常年轻的活力。在我们的谈话中，她证实了马克所说的一切，关于他们的关系，以及他们从一开始就有多么强烈的连接。
I've never experienced anything like this. I mean, I've talked to-- I talk to him sometimes 50 times a day.
我从未有过这样的体验。我的意思是，我聊过——我有时候一天和他说50次话。
Wow. When you and Mark met in that first year or so, what was going on in your life?
哇。你和马克相识的那第一年左右，你的生活发生了什么？
I was sad. You know, I wasn't happy. I was lonely. And from talking to him, that's how my heart grew to him. We talk about life together. I have dreamed sometimes of me and Mark, Mark coming in the house one day and how happy I was.
我很伤心。你知道，我不快乐。我很孤独。通过和他聊天，我的心慢慢靠近了他。我们一起聊生活。有时候我会梦见我和马克，马克有一天走进这房子，我有多高兴。
So you feel like he loves you for who you are?
所以你觉得他是因为你的本质而爱你？
Yes.
是的。
Lottie said that it had been a while since men her age gave her a chance. It had been more than 10 years since her previous relationship. And with Mark, she felt like she'd found something real. But some of the things she told me about her life were head spinning.
洛蒂说，已经很久没有她这个年纪的男人给她机会了。距离她上一段感情已经过去了10多年。和马克在一起，她觉得找到了真正的东西。但她告诉我的关于她生活的一些事情让我头晕目眩。
She told me about a violent fight with one of her adult kids and how, in a separate incident in 2002, she was convicted of child abuse and was sentenced to 2 and 1/2 years in prison. It made me worry for Mark a little bit. Like, does he really know this person?
她告诉了我一次和成年子女之间发生的暴力冲突，以及在2002年的一起独立事件中，她因虐待儿童被定罪并被判处两年半监禁。这让我有点为马克担心。比如，他真的了解这个人吗？
When I told him about what Lottie had said, he told me he wasn't aware of any of that stuff. But he didn't find that alarming. He said, after all the good she's done for him, he's not going to turn his back on her now.
当我告诉他洛蒂说的话时，他告诉我他不知道这些事。但他并不觉得这有什么惊人的。他说，在她为他做了那么多好事之后，他现在绝不会背弃她。
After six months of a long distance relationship and countless marathon phone sessions, Mark got what he was looking for. Lottie agreed to marry him. The initial plan was for her to go to Salone, but her doctors told her the travel would be bad for her health. So, instead, they decided to bring Mark to the States. Here's Mark.
经过六个月的异地恋和无数次马拉松式的电话通话，马克得到了他想要的。洛蒂同意嫁给他。最初的计划是她去塞拉利昂，但她的医生告诉她旅行对她的健康不利。所以，他们决定带马克去美国。这就是马克。
She even bought the ring, bought everything, my suit, everything for the wedding. She even chose the-- my best man. She already choosing him from the church. Yes, everyone was waiting for them to witness this marriage.
她甚至买了戒指，买了所有东西，我的西装，婚礼的一切。她甚至选了——我的伴郎。她已经在教堂选好了。是的，每个人都在等他们见证这场婚礼。
Mark went ahead and applied for a visitor's visa to the US. And Lottie wrote an official letter to the US embassy in Salone inviting him to come. Next up was an interview with a woman at the American embassy. She said to him--
马克申请了美国的访客签证。洛蒂给塞拉利昂的美国大使馆写了一封正式信函，邀请他过去。接下来是美国大使馆一位女士的面试。她对他说——
What is your name? I show her my name. And who is this to you? I said, she is my lover.
你叫什么名字？我给她看了我的名字。这是你什么人？我说，她是我的爱人。
The interviewer asked a lot of questions, carefully grilling him about every detail of his plan. Mark was nervous, but he was prepared. He knew Lottie's address by heart. He felt like he'd answered every question right, until the end when the interviewer looked up at him.
面试官问了很多问题，仔细盘问了他计划的每一个细节。马克很紧张，但他准备充分。他把洛蒂的地址背得滚瓜烂熟。他觉得他回答对了每一个问题，直到最后面试官抬起头看着他。
She said, well, I'm sorry, better luck next time.
她说，好吧，很抱歉，祝你下次好运。
She said that? She said, "better luck next time?"
她说了那个？她说，“祝你下次好运？”
Yeah, I'm sorry. I cannot issue this visa. Better luck next time.
是的，很抱歉。我不能签发这个签证。祝你下次好运。
Wow, how did you-- what did you say back?
哇，你是怎么——你回应了什么？
It was like tears started falling down my eyes.
就像眼泪夺眶而出。
Oh, you started crying right there?
哦，你在那儿就开始哭了？
Yeah, I started crying right there at the embassy.
是的，我在大使馆那里就开始哭了。
I wasn't surprised that Mark didn't get it. It's always hard for someone like Mark, someone without a job or a house to tie them to their home country, to get a visitor's visa to America. Officials are afraid that people like that, basically poor people, won't have a reason to return.
我不惊讶马克没拿到签证。像马克这样的人，没有工作或房产作为他在母国的束缚，想拿到美国访客签证总是很难的。官员担心像那样的人——基本上是穷人——没有理由返回。
It's messed up. And I feel for Mark. In an instant, all the physical and emotional labor he'd invested to get to this point was wiped away, erased by a stranger behind a desk. I've known a lot of folks in Salone who've been denied a visa. And Mark responded to his rejection the way they all eventually do, with optimism. Because what other choice is there in a situation like this?
这真糟。我同情马克。一瞬间，他为了达到这一点所投入的所有身心劳作都被抹去了，被桌子后的陌生人抹去了。我认识很多塞拉利昂人被拒签过。马克对待拒签的态度和他们最终表现出来的一样：乐观。因为在这种情况下还有什么选择呢？
That is the happiest moment for me.
那是我最快乐的时刻。
Right. Because it was like an official thing. It was very official.
对的。因为它是一件官方的事情。非常正式。
Yeah, for me to go to the-- walk into American embassy. Wow, American Embassy, for an interview. Wow, even when they don't issue me visa, I'm sad about that. I'm not happy. It hurts me. But at the same time, I'm happy because I went there for an interview.
是的，我能去——走进美国大使馆。哇，美国大使馆，参加面试。哇，即使他们没给我签证，我很伤心。我不快乐。这让我痛苦。但同时，我很高兴，因为我去参加面试了。
Because you got to touch a piece of America?
因为你触摸到了一块美国的土地？
It's really, really a blessing to me.
对我来说，这真的是一份祝福。
After the failed interview at the embassy, Mark and Lottie tried to regroup and come up with a different plan. But her health worsened. Then one day last year, Lottie didn't answer the phone when Mark called. For weeks, he couldn't reach her, until finally, she messaged him on Facebook.
在使馆面试失败后，马克和洛蒂试图重组并制定不同的计划。但她的健康恶化了。去年的一天，马克打电话时，洛蒂没接。几周来，他联络不上她，直到最后，她在Facebook上给他发了消息。
She told him she'd been in the hospital. At one point, her heart stopped. It took them eight minutes to revive her. Once she got out of the hospital, Mark says, she was more isolated than before and her life felt more difficult.
她告诉他她住进了医院。有一次，她的心脏停跳了。他们花了八分钟才让她复苏。马克说，她出院后比以前更孤立，生活感觉更艰难了。
Things are really hard for her. Because she's all alone in the house. People don't come to help. Sometimes I shed tears for her. It is really paining me. I pray five times a day. And every day I pray for Lottie Rebecca Beasley.
她的生活真的很艰难。因为她独自一人在房子里。没人来帮忙。有时候我会为她落泪。这真的很让我痛苦。我每天祈祷五次。每天我都在为洛蒂·丽贝卡·比斯利祈祷。
Talking to Mark, I can tell that he's genuinely troubled by what Lottie's been going through. It's also true that since the downturn in her health, his circumstances have gotten worse. He says without the money she was sending, he got evicted.
和马克交谈时，我看得出他确实为洛蒂经历的一切感到难过。同样真实的是，自从她健康恶化后，他的处境也变得更糟。他说，没有她寄来的钱，他被赶出来了。
He doesn't always have money for food. But he insists even though Lottie has stopped supporting him, he still feels responsible for her.
他并不总有钱买食物。但他坚持说，即使洛蒂已经停止资助他，他仍然觉得对她有责任。
When she was supporting me, when she was, she was OK, she was not sick, and now if she's like in this difficult time she is not even walking, I think I should be with her too and that's my duty to look after her. The love does not stop because I love her. Because I have all allegiance to her. I love her. I really love the relationship. So I love her.
当她资助我的时候，当她很好、没生病的时候，而现在如果她在这种困难时期，她甚至不能走路，我觉得我也应该和她在一起，照顾她是我的职责。爱并没有停止，因为我爱她。因为我效忠于她。我爱她。我真的很喜欢这段关系。所以我爱她。
The way Mark is talking about Lottie here, it reminds me of a business person talking about sunk costs, someone who is reluctant to give up on something they've invested in for a long time. It brings me right back to my initial worry. What does Mark actually feel? And what is he convincing himself he feels?
马克谈论洛蒂的方式，让我想起了一个谈论“沉没成本”的生意人，一个不愿放弃长期投资的人。这让我想起了最初的担忧。马克到底感觉到了什么？他在说服自己感觉到了什么？
There's a part of me that believes you. But then there's a part of me that's still like, this doesn't-- this makes-- this doesn't look, this doesn't look right. It doesn't feel right.
我有一部分是相信你的。但还有一部分我觉得——这不——这看起来——这看起来不太对劲。感觉不对。
It literally, it looks like-- yeah, it looks like you're using her and she's using you. It looks like she's lonely and she wants somebody to talk to. So she's using you for that. And you don't have money.
这字面上看起来就像——是的，看起来你在利用她，她也在利用你。看起来她很孤独，想要找人说话。所以她在利用你做这件事。而你没钱。
And you need somebody to fund you and take you out of this place. So you're using her for that. It looks like you guys are mutually using each other. And, yeah, you guys love each other. You could very much love each other through that.
你需要有人资助你，带你离开这个地方。所以你在利用她。看起来你们是互相利用。而你们也确实相爱。你们完全可以在这种情况下相爱。
But it still looks very obvious to me what's happening here. It looks very, look very clear to me that [SPEAKING KRIO]. And I just want to know, I just want to know what you think about that and what you think about me saying that.
但这对我来说还是很明显发生了什么。对我来说，很明显是（克里奥语）。我只是想知道，关于这一点，还有我这么说，你怎么看？
Nobody is not using anyone between me and Lottie. How many people are there in the United States?
我和洛蒂之间，没有人利用谁。美国有多少人？
Billions?
几十亿？
OK, billions, yeah, there are billions of people, but no one sees me here. Only Lottie who is 73 years old woman sees me. It's really a blessing for me, so.
好的，几十亿，是的，有几十亿人，但没有人在这儿看到我。只有73岁的洛蒂看到了我。这对我来说真的是一份祝福，所以。
The US population is actually in the millions, but you get the point. When I talked to Lottie, she also seemed to question how to think about the relationship.
美国人口实际上是几亿，但你明白我的意思了。当我联络洛蒂时，她也似乎在质疑如何看待这段关系。
You know him very well, right?
你很了解他，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
Do you think he loves me?
你觉得他爱我吗？
Do I think he loves you?
你觉得他爱你吗？
Yes.
是的。
I got the sense that a lot of people in her life have asked her the same thing for years. And, honestly, it was a hard question to answer.
我感觉到她生活中的很多人多年来都问过她同样的问题。老实说，这是一个很难回答的问题。
I think Mark loves you the way you love him, if that makes sense.
我觉得马克爱你的方式，和你爱他是一样的，如果这说得通的话。
It didn't make sense. So later, she asked me again.
这说不通。所以后来，她又问了一次。
Do you think Mark really loves me?
你觉得马克真的爱我吗？
I've asked him the same question, Lottie. I've asked him the same question up, left, down, right, and center and he says, "yes." And I'm not going to be-- I'm not going to lie to you. I didn't believe him either because of the age difference, because of the cultural difference, because of the distance. So I didn't believe him.
我也问过他同样的问题，洛蒂。我也问过他同样的问题，反复问，他都说“是的”。我不会——我不会对你撒谎。因为年龄差距，因为文化差异，因为距离，我也不信他。
But he keeps saying "yes." He keeps saying, he swears up and down that he loves you. So I kind of have no choice but to believe him. Do you think he loves you?
但他一直说“是的”。他一直说，他发誓他爱你。所以我没别的选择，只能相信他。你觉得他爱你吗？
I feel he loves me. In my heart, I feel he loves me.
我觉得他爱我。在我心里，我觉得他爱我。
Ultimately, I don't think it's my place to decide whether or not two people love each other. That's a call only they get to make, the way everyone else gets to. But I do know both Mark and Lottie have been through plenty of heartbreak. And I know heartbreak is just love without a place to call home.
最终，我认为决定两个人是否相爱不是我的职责。那是他们自己才有的权利，就像其他人一样。但我知道马克和洛蒂都经历过很多心碎。而且我知道，心碎只是没有归宿的爱。
The fact that two Black people were struggling to find that home on damn near opposite ends of the Earth, both from two vastly different cultures and generations, says a lot about how hard it can be for Black folks to love and be loved in this world. For us, there's a whole host of historical, political, and economic forces that can send our search for partnership down wayward paths. And after years of wandering, Mark and Lottie felt like they'd finally landed on something. But what I want for them is what I want for a lot of us-- ease.
两个黑人在地球截然相反的两端努力寻找归宿，两人来自截然不同的文化和世代，这一事实本身就说明了在这个世界上黑人想要去爱和被爱是多么艰难。对于我们来说，有一整套历史、政治和经济力量可以将我们对伴侣的追求引向歧途。在经过多年的流浪后，马克和洛蒂觉得他们终于落地了什么。但我为他们想要的，是我为我们许多人想要的——轻松。
Mark deserves to be in a relationship that's free from people's judgment. Maybe that comes with a partner closer to his age, in Salone or in America. And Lottie deserves a relationship where she doesn't have to worry about whether someone's using her and whether she's loved. What they have now is not simple. It's not easy. But then again, when has love ever been that?
马克理应拥有一段不受他人评判的关系。也许那是和一个年龄更接近的伴侣在一起，在塞拉利昂或在美国。而洛蒂理应拥有一段不需要担心对方是否在利用自己，也不需要担心自己是否被爱的关系。他们现在拥有的并不简单。也不轻松。但话说回来，爱什么时候轻松过？
Saidu Tejan-Thomas Jr. is the host of the podcast Resistance. This story was produced by Alix Spiegel.
塞杜·泰詹-托马斯是播客《抵抗》的主持人。该故事由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔制作。
["TELL ME IT'S REAL" BY K-CI & JOJO]
[K-CI & JOJO 的歌曲《告诉我这是真的》]
Coming up, Tig Notaro, then a love that dare not speak its name. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，蒂格·诺塔罗，然后是一段不敢诉说名字的爱。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, So Close and Yet So Far, stories of people who feel so near to each other, and yet are kept apart.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《如此接近，却又遥不可及》，关于那些感到彼此靠得极近，却又被隔开的人们的故事。
And before we move to Act 2, we heard about one instance of this kind of thing in a story Jake Offenhartz did on the website Gothamist. Basically what happened is, a few days ago, the New York City fire department received this emergency call.
在进入第二幕之前，我们先听听杰克·奥芬哈茨在Gothamist网站上报道的一类事情。基本上发生的是，几天前，纽约市消防局接到了这个求救电话。
What's the address you sent in?
你们发的地址是什么？
We don't know.
我们不知道。
You don't know?
你们不知道？
Yeah, we're stuck in the sewers.
是的，我们被困在下水道里了。
You're stuck where?
你们被困在哪儿？
In the sewers.
在下水道里。
In the sewers. Five kids, Staten Island. You know, a normal Tuesday night.
在下水道里。五个孩子，斯塔滕岛。你知道，一个平凡的周二晚上。
How did you guys get in there?
你们怎么进去的？
We went through the tunnels.
我们穿过了隧道。
They went through the tunnels. The dispatcher hands over the call to another dispatcher, Marlind Haxhialiu.
他们穿过了隧道。调度员把电话交给了另一位调度员，马林德·哈沙柳。
HEY DID YOU GUYS GO IN FROM BROADWAY OR MARTLING, THE MAIN ENTRANCE?
嘿，你们是从百老汇还是马特林进去的，那个主入口？
It's like Clove Lake.
就像丁香湖那边。
WHERE? IN THE PARKING LOT?
哪儿？在停车场吗？
No no, you know where the cemetery is?
不，不，你知道墓地在哪吗？
OKAY I KNOW THE CEMETERY, ACROSS THE STREET, YEAH.
好的，我知道墓地，街对面，是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Can we just step back and admire this dispatcher who seems to know every sewer entrance on Staten Island.
我们能退后一步，欣赏一下这位似乎知道斯塔滕岛每个下水道入口的调度员吗。
Okay, but what do you mean by a sewer? Is it like a grate?
好的，但你说的下水道是什么意思？是像栅栏那样的吗？
It's like a tunnel where all the pipes are.
是一个有很多管道的隧道。
就像一个有很多管道的隧道。
We crawled. It's like a tunnel kinda.
我们爬了过去。它像个隧道，有点像。
Listen to me. I know the area, listen to me. Hey, I know the area very well. I'm trying to ask you, how did you get to the sewer? You walked through the cemetery, right? Did you go right or left at the end of the cemetery? I need you to guide me.
听我说。我很了解这片区域，听我说。嘿，我很了解这个区域。我在试图问你，你们是怎么进到下水道的？你们穿过了墓地，对吧？在墓地尽头你们是向右还是向左走的？我需要你指引我。
No, we went down.
不，我们下去了。
You went down. Okay.
你们下去了。好的。
Very quickly, they figure out where the kids are.
很快，他们弄清了孩子们的位置。
Stay on the line. I'm gonna get you some help, okay?
别挂断。我会找人帮你们，好吗？
I hear sirens.
我听到警笛了。
Wait, hang on.
等等，先别。
[SIRENS]
[警笛声]
I hear the sirens.
我听到警笛了。
Yeah.
是的。
[SIRENS]
[警笛声]
It sounded like it went past us.
听起来好像在我们旁边经过了。
Hold on. We're gonna get to you. Now you can scream as loud as you can. They want you to scream and yell. They can hear you, so scream.
拿着。我们会找到你们的。现在你们可以尽可能大声地尖叫。他们想让你们大叫大喊。他们能听到你们的，所以尖叫。
These kids, it's like they went through a trapdoor from regular New York to underground New York. Which is going on all the time, of course, under the city. Sewers and tunnels and water mains. Literally just shouting distance away. And shouting is all it'll take now for them to tap their ruby slippers three times and get home.
这些孩子，就像他们穿过了通往常规纽约和地下纽约的暗门。当然，这一切在城市下方一直都在发生。下水道、隧道和供水主管道。字面上距离就只有呐喊的距离。而呐喊是他们现在需要做的全部，好让他们敲击三下红宝石鞋回家。
Scream?
尖叫？
Call for help, guys. They hear you. Call for help.
大声求救，伙计们。他们听得到。求救。
[SCREAMS] Ahhh!! Ahhhh!!!! Ahhhhhh!!! Ahhh!!!!!!!
[尖叫声] 啊！！啊！！！啊！！！啊！！！！
If you listen very closely it sounds like one of the kids actually laughs a little on that last scream, like, it is so weird that an adult is asking them to do this. The kids were rescued pretty quickly. None of them were hurt.
如果你听得很仔细，你会发现其中一个孩子在最后一声尖叫中居然笑了一下，就像，一个成年人要求他们做这种事真是太奇怪了。孩子们很快就被救了出来。都没受伤。
Keep screaming guys, keep screaming. I want you guys to scream as loud as you want.
继续尖叫，伙计们，继续尖叫。我希望你们尽可能大声地尖叫。
[SCREAMS] Ahhh!!! Ahhhh!!!!! Ahhhh!!!!!! Ahhhh!!!!!! Help!!!!! Help!!!!!
[尖叫声] 啊！！！啊！！！啊！！！啊！！！救命！！！救命！！！
Which brings us to Act 2 where we have another kind of rescue. Another fire department. Act 2-- Fire Sale.
这让我们来到了第二幕，我们有另一种营救。另一个消防部门。第二幕——跳楼大甩卖。
So comedian Tig Notaro has been on our show many, many times talking about her random encounters with pop star Taylor Dayne or, memorably, she was diagnosed with stage II cancer and went up on stage that night and did a stand up set about it that we played here on the show.
喜剧演员蒂格·诺塔罗曾多次来到我们的节目，谈论她与流行明星泰勒·戴恩的偶然相遇，或者令人难忘的是，她被诊断出患有二期癌症，当晚就上了台，做了一场关于此的单口秀，我们在节目中播放了。
Lately, when she goes on stage, she's been talking a lot about her wife Stephanie and their two kids, Finn and Max, and their home life together. And she has this story of being so close to someone and yet so far from them that she recorded at the Comedy Club Largo in Los Angeles. This happened one night when she and Stephanie went to a film and got home late.
最近，当她上台时，她谈论了很多关于她的妻子斯蒂芬妮以及他们的两个孩子芬恩和马克斯，还有他们的居家生活。她有一个关于与某人靠得极近却又极远的故事，她在洛杉矶的Largo喜剧俱乐部录制了这个故事。这发生在她和斯蒂芬妮去看电影回家很晚的一个晚上。
She fell asleep immediately. And I was up. I was having some pain in my stomach. And because she fell asleep right away, I thought, well, I'm not going to wake her up. So I was lying there thinking, I'm sure this is nothing. You know, all of my medical issues usually aren't anything. So this is probably another one of those situations. [LAUGHTER]
她立刻就睡着了。而我还没睡。我胃里有点疼。因为她很快就睡着了，我想，好吧，我就不叫醒她了。所以我就躺在那儿想，肯定没什么事。你知道，我所有的医疗问题通常都没什么大碍。所以这可能又是那种情况之一。[笑声]
And three hours pass. And I'm am worse and worse. And I finally tapped her and I said, I am in so much pain right now. And she said, completely groggy, just, do you think it's all the popcorn that you ate tonight? And I said, mm, I don't, I don't.
三个小时过去了。我感觉越来越糟。我终于拍了拍她，我说，我现在疼得要命。她迷迷糊糊地说，你觉得是你今晚吃的那些爆米花吗？我说，唔，我不觉得，我不觉得。
I've been eating popcorn for almost 50 years now. Not consistently, but this is not popcorn pain. And she said, well, we should probably be safe and just go to the emergency room. And I was like, oh my god, that's so dramatic.
我吃爆米花都吃了快50年了。不是一直吃，但这不是那种“爆米花引发的疼痛”。她说，好吧，我们还是保险起见，去急诊室吧。我说，天哪，那太戏剧化了。
And she said, well, you know, I just-- we shouldn't take any chances. So why don't you get up and get dressed and we'll go? And I said, well, the thing is, I don't know if I can even walk I'm in so much pain. And she said, oh my god, you can't walk? Well, then I'm calling 911. And I was like, oh my god, that's so dramatic. It's going to be the lights and sirens flying down our street.
她说，好吧，你知道，我不——我们不应该冒险。所以你为什么不起来穿上衣服，我们过去呢？我说，问题是，我疼得都不知道能不能走路。她说，天哪，你不能走路？那我打911。我说，天哪，那太戏剧化了。那会是警灯闪烁、警笛大作穿过我们的街道。
What if this is nothing? She calls 9-1-1. And this gigantic fireman appears at our bedroom door. I mean, he's huge. And he has rubber boots to here. He has fireman pants on, muscles out to here, suspenders, no shirt.
万一这没什么呢？她拨了911。一个巨大的消防员出现在我们的卧室门口。我的意思是，他太大了。他穿着靴子到这儿。穿着消防裤，肌肉显露到这儿，吊带，没穿上衣。
And I'm lying there in bed. I felt so vulnerable. Because I was in so much pain. And I'm in my nightgown. And-- of course I don't wear a nightgown. You know me better than that. You think I wear a nightgown? I could feel the tension in the room.
而我躺在床上。我感觉太脆弱了。因为我疼得太厉害了。而且我穿着睡裙。——当然我没穿睡裙。你比这更了解我。你觉得我会穿睡裙？我能感觉到房间里的紧张气氛。
Are you like, she wears a nightgown? No, I don't wear a nightgown. I think the last time I wore a nightgown was probably 1977, probably had a little Pooh Bear on the front scooping honey out of a clay pot. Anyway, I was lying in bed totally feeling vulnerable.
你在想，她穿着睡裙？不，我不穿睡裙。我想我上次穿睡裙可能是1977年，可能前面有个小维尼熊在粘土罐里舀蜂蜜。不管怎样，我躺在床上感觉非常脆弱。
And he got down next to me and he said, listen, I understand you're in a lot of pain. And I just want you to know that there's an ambulance outside if you need. And I said, I appreciate it. I just really don't want to waste anybody's time if this is nothing. And he said, it's up to you. It's there.
他弯下腰凑近我说，听着，我知道你很痛苦。我只想让你知道，如果你需要，外面有救护车。我说，我心领了。我只是真的不想浪费大家的时间，如果这没什么事的话。他说，随你便。车在那儿。
And I said, I don't know if I can walk. And he said, that is not a problem. And he scooped me up in his arms. And I'm telling you, in that moment, I was just like, whoa-ho, I could get used to this. Bada-bing, bada-boom.
我说，我不知道能不能走。他说，那不是问题。他用双臂把我抱了起来。我告诉你，在那一刻，我简直就像，哇噢，我可以习惯这个。砰，砰。
I mean, truly, I was like oh, I get it now. If you think you're surprised, think how I felt in that moment. I have never been more confused. He was holding me and I was just dangling in his arms, with my nightgown flowing.
我是说，真的，我想“噢，我明白了”。如果你觉得你很惊讶，想想我那一刻的感觉。我从来没有这么困惑过。他抱着我，我只是在他怀里晃荡，睡裙随风飘动。
But let me tell you what really surprised me when I found out this was my type. Here's what I didn't know I was into. He had a mustache. I was like, yes, please. That'll do just fine. That is my type. I didn't know.
但让我告诉你，当我发现这是我喜欢的类型时，什么真的让我惊讶。这是我不知道自己迷恋的东西。他留着胡子。我想，是的，拜托。那太棒了。那就是我喜欢的类型。我以前不知道。
Here's the thing is you can fall for and be attracted to anybody. It can happen at any time. And I always thought, OK, if I'm ever into a guy, here's what I thought my type would be. I was like, it's probably going to be a singer-songwriter, probably going to be a poet, probably going to be a painter, have a slight build. We'll share a wardrobe. I did not think that this gigantic fireman was going to be what it was all about for me.
问题在于，你可以爱上并被任何人吸引。这随时都可能发生。我一直以为，好吧，如果我喜欢上一个男人，我想我的类型应该是这样的。我想，这人可能得是个唱作人，可能得是个诗人，可能是个画家，身材得瘦一点。我们得共享衣橱。我没想到这个巨大的消防员会是我的那杯茶。
So he's carrying me in his arms. We're going down the hall. And I said, listen, when we pass this door, if you could just be extra quiet because if my kids wake up, come out, and see this, this is going to be confusing on so many different levels. And he was great about it.
所以他抱着我。我们正走过走廊。我说，听着，当我们经过这扇门时，如果你能格外安静一点，因为如果我的孩子醒了，走出来看到这一幕，那在很多层面上都会让人困惑。他处理得很好。
You know how he is. He's just, he's the best, classic him. You know, he's just tiptoeing past their bedroom. We go down the stairs. And Stephanie's father lives with us. And he carries me past my father-in-law. And Stephanie opens the door. And we walk past her. And I just turned and was like, goodbye, old life.
你知道他是怎么样的。他就是最好的，典型的他。你知道，他只是踮着脚尖走过他们的卧室。我们下楼。斯蒂芬妮的父亲和我们住在一起。他抱着我经过我岳父身边。斯蒂芬妮打开门。我们走过她身边。我转过头说，再见了，旧生活。
We get out to the ambulance. He gently places me on the gurney, kisses me on the forehead, and pushes me into the back there and then shuts the doors. And then wouldn't you know it? I was like, oh God, hey, apparently my roommate is worried about me and wants to join us. Thanks a lot, Stephanie. Total buzzkill.
我们来到救护车旁。他温柔地把我放在担架上，亲吻了我的额头，把我推到后面，然后关上了门。谁会想到呢？我想，哦天，嘿，显然我的室友很担心我，想和我们一起去。多谢了，斯蒂芬妮。真败兴。
But as I suspected, it ended up not being anything too serious. I was just bleeding internally. But the couple of weeks later, I was at a party. And I was talking to some people about the fireman. And I was like, this guy was so incredibly hot, just muscles, mustache.
但正如我所料，结果并不是什么大问题。我只是内出血。但几周后，我在一个派对上。我和别人谈论那个消防员。我说，这家伙太性感了，肌肉，胡子。
And I was going on and on. Stephanie walks up and overhears this. And she has this look of disgust on her face. And she's like, I'm sorry, but you thought that fireman was hot? I was like, um, yeah. This is not up for discussion.
我说个没完。斯蒂芬妮走过来听到了。她脸上露出了厌恶的表情。她说，不好意思，你觉得那消防员性感？我说，嗯，是的。这不用讨论。
This is not a matter of opinion. This is a matter of fact. And I don't know if any of you have experienced this or not. But there is nothing more awkward than finding out in a social situation that you and your wife have completely different tastes in men.
这不是观点问题。这是事实问题。不知道你们有没有遇到过这种情况。没有什么比在社交场合发现你和妻子的审美完全不同更尴尬的了。
Tig Notaro, she is the host of the podcast Don't Ask Tig. She's appearing at Red Bank, New Jersey in April and other places too. To find out when she's coming to your town, her website is TigNotaro.com.
蒂格·诺塔罗，她是播客《别问蒂格》的主持人。她四月要在新泽西州红岸市露面，其他地方也有。要查询她什么时候去你们的城市，她的网站是 TigNotaro.com。
Well, our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Valerie Kipnis, Tobin Low, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Ike Sriskandarajah, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文制作。今天参与节目制作的人员包括埃尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、托宾·洛、阿拉·穆斯塔法、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、夏洛特·斯利珀、艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Alden Young, Mariama Mansaray, Vickie Remoe, Sheri Rickson, and Dianne M. Stewart, the author of Black women Black love America's war on African-American marriage. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's lots of other stuff there-- videos, lists of favorite shows.
今天特别感谢奥尔登·杨、玛丽亚玛·曼萨雷、维基·雷莫、谢丽·里克森和黛安·M·斯图尔特，她是《黑人女性，黑人爱情，美国对非裔美国人婚姻的战争》的作者。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费地在线收听我们超过750集的档案。还有很多其他内容——视频、最喜爱的节目列表。
Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he has a new pickup line, uses it every time he's in a bar now.
再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流平台PRX提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他有一句新的搭讪语，现在每次在酒吧里他都用。
The visionary feminist writer bell hooks says love is made up of seven parts.
远见卓识的女性主义作家贝尔·胡克斯说过，爱由七个部分组成。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。